your party
yes entirely so and why I just want to
say we're looking at uh Boris Johnson's
plane landing back at gapwick airport he
was obviously in the Dominican Republic
Republic he's returning this morning
just about to touch down hang on a
second they are just about to touch down
at Gatwick should we wait for that
here we go Boris Johnson coming back
we assumed to run in the leadership race
oh there there we go a smooth Landing so
he's back
um
you you don't think that Boris Johnson
is the one to unite the Tory Brothers I
I think when you see what people are
saying out there and what
what commentators are making a point
about which is that it would be wrong
for him to come back there is still the
outstanding privileges committee there
are a whole host of issues as to why
Boris can come back we are trying to get
if those who are supporting him are
expecting a different result they're not
going to get it and I think we've got to
be absolutely clear right now the scale
of the global economic crisis that is
being faced by so many countries around
the world needs people who've got the
grass economically to deal with the
situation to be able to ensure that we
can get through this stuff Theory and to
me it's absolutely clear that Richardson
is the only candidate available to be
able to do this and to get us through
and to unite the party as you asked
earlier okay well we shall see you
tomorrow and thank you so much for
talking to us
okay well as I was saying there Bosch
Johnson has now landed on that beer
flight back from the Dominican Republic
just touched down at Gatwick Airport
let's bring in Ali Fortescue Ali he's
back in the country but do we think he
will be back in politics
I mean it I think a few days ago this
seemed quite far-fetched but you know he
there's his plane he's back in the
country allies close to him have told us
that he is up for it he wants another go
at the top job I think the big question
well there's two questions one will he
meet the threshold of 100 MPS and that
is no guarantee whatsoever I think you
know people think he will get to 60 but
beyond that will be more challenging but
if there is momentum behind him could we
see some people rowing in behind the
former prime minister
um if that looks like that's the win the
way the wind is blowing could he just
get over 100 MPS what is clear is that
Rishi sunak is at the moment the firm
favorite with MPS it looks like he has
made it onto the ballot his part his um
his campaign saying that he has more
than a hundred
votes of course Rishi sunak and Boris
Johnson I think it's fair to say there's
no love lost between these two Rishi
sunak seen by many as a person that took
down Boris Johnson when he resigned in
office triggering of course such a Javid
also resigned triggering a wave of
resignations that eventually toppled
Boris Johnson's government
um there has been some talk in some of
the papers that we could see a Johnson
sunac Alliance the two men coming
together former Rivals to bring the
party together but I've had a few
conversations with people close to both
of those men and it from the
conversations I've had you cannot see
either of them serving in the other
one's cabinet
as I say you know I haven't spoken to
everyone we don't we don't know what is
going to happen politics has been
incredibly unpredictable but it is I
think hard for many to see these two men
working together let's not forget Penny
Morden she her name has also been in the
mix she is
um got I think 19 people backing her at
the moment but there are some who worry
that she does not have the momentum
behind her at the moment and she might
not make it onto that final ballot so
will this be I think either a coronation
for Rishi sunak on Monday who is the
favorite at the moment the firm favorite
among MPS or will Boris Johnson or Penny
Morden to make it on onto that final
ballad and we know that Boris Johnson
does very well with a membership I
certainly sensed that over the summer
when I was at the hustings there was
Anger from some tools Rishi sunak from
what they perceive to be him stabbing
Boris Johnson in the back but will what
has happened over the course of the last
six weeks Liz truss's Premiership many
Rishi sunak backers feel Vindicated by
what has happened in the last couple of
months will that change members Minds as
I say we don't know what is going to
happen we don't know if Boris Johnson's
even standing
um people close to him have told have
told some of us that it looks like he we
will want to go for the job we don't
know if he he has always been someone
that has never failed to surprise us or
we don't know if he wants to be the next
prime minister if he is even going to
put his name forward I think he will
want to know that he can win this if
he's going to enter the race of course
Rishi sunak hasn't entered himself
either so we're in a pretty
extraordinary position right now where
penny more than the only person to
officially enter the race she has I
think 19 votes last time I checked Rishi
sunak and Boris Johnson are the Front
Runners Rishi sunak by far the front
runner when it comes to MPS backing him
but neither of those two men have
actually put their names in the Hat yet
so who will be the next prime minister
we don't know we will know either on
Monday next week and certainly by Friday
next week two days two days um Ali I
just want to to talk about something you
mentioned there and how this is playing
out first of all with the MPS and then
with the members of the Tory party I was
talking to Auntie Emmanuel um he's a
conservative MP he's backing where she's
like and I brought up the fact that a
lot of people do indeed think that Rishi
sunak stabbed Boris Johnson in the back
by resigning and he rejoicing and said
absolutely not and that is of course
what you would expect from rishi's
supporters and a lot of them say that
but how do the MPS feel about it and how
do members of the party feel about what
happened and how Boris Johnson left
office
I think there is a great strength of
feeling on both sides when it comes to
Boris Johnson I think there are people
who think the idea of him coming back I
find that quite upsetting some MPS I've
spoken to
um you know there's a couple uh Roger
Gayle others who have suggested they
would leave the Parliamentary party if
Boris Johnson comes back there are those
that adamant name I mean Nadine Doris is
probably the best characterization of
this but we know he's got the backing of
some big names including Jacob Reese
mogg Ben Wallace suggested he would
potentially back Boris Johnson so Boris
Johnson I think elicits strong feelings
on both sides but in a sense the same
can be said to an extent I think for
Rishi sunac there were certainly first
time around people that didn't want to
see him be prime minister and there are
still those that don't
um but I have to say some of those views
seem to have softened I was talking to
one minister there who didn't want Rishi
sunak to be prime minister first time
round but has decided that what has
happened in the last few weeks with the
economy he is a man that can study this
so I think there are those who have
softened their approach having not
wanted Rishi sunak to be prime minister
um and I think you see that reflected in
the numbers
um so I think but I do think you know
these there is no clear Unity candidate
here Penny morden's team might say that
she is the unity candidate but I don't
think there is anyone that is clearly
going to bridge The Divide and that is
going to be the enormous challenge
forever becomes the next prime minister
okay ali um just to just to let you know
what you're looking at that's a British
Airways flight that has just touched
down in Gatwick Airport it came from
Punta Cana International Airport in the
Dominican Republic it is carrying Boris
Johnson
um and he he's back in the UK I just
want to go uh Ali back to you and ask
just a final question this issue of the
Privileges committee process just talk
us through that and what could happen
because if he does become leader he
still could lose his seat through the
process couldn't he yes so
this is the Privileges committee they
are looking at whether Boris Johnson
misled Parliament
um over parties which of course was one
of the big
um one of the big things that brought
down the former prime minister what was
going on in Downing street during
lockdown the Privileges committee are
looking at that that means that over the
next few weeks
um or months they'll be taking evidence
and that is something that people like
Dominic Robb who is Deputy Prime
Minister under Boris Johnson think will
be as he put it this morning incredibly
distracting and not what you want from
the man the man who's going to be prime
minister and as you say could
potentially uh mean that he has to stand
down so it is it is a pretty
extraordinary situation to be in I think
you know his backers will say that he
didn't do anything wrong he'll clear his
name but
Dominic Robb Deputy Prime Minister under
Boris Johnson this morning saying that
that would be a huge distraction he said
he thinks Boris Johnson could return to
Frontline politics but he this is not
the time for him to be prime minister
and that is certainly what Rishi sunak
backers will say today
okay Ali thank you so much uh just to
tell you again Boris Johnson has arrived
back in the UK that's his Bo flight just
touched down at Gatwick Airport from the
Dominican Republic I'm waiting to see
what happens as the next two days play
out and indeed see if he declares his
candidacy but we will come back to that
as and when and Ali we will come back to
you thank you so much